crazy things going on in the capitol i'm
not talking about january 6th i'm
talking about
the most bizarre hearing that i have
ever seen take place in the united
states senate and i had to check myself
on this i have not spent a lot of time
around the u.s senate but i spoke last
night to senator ted cruz and i said hey
man you were in that hearing today uh
that was pretty nuts right and he said
michael in my decade in the senate i
have never seen anything crazier the
hearing was about
abortion there was one
person in particular who was testifying
berkeley law professor kiara bridges
who
had
had the entire testimony descend into a
debate over whether or not men can get
pregnant this this occurred in
particular during an exchange with
senator josh hawley this exchange is a
little bit long trust me it's worth it
you've referred to people with a
capacity for pregnancy
would that be women
many women cis women have the capacity
for pregnancy many cis women do not have
the capacity for pregnancy
there are also trans men who are capable
of pregnancy as well as non-binary
people who are capable of pregnancy so
this isn't really a women's rights issue
it's uh we can recognize that this
impacts women while also recognizing
that it impacts other groups those
things are not mutually exclusive
senator hawley oh so your view is is
that the core of this this right then is
about what
so um i want to recognize that your line
of questioning um is transphobic
um and it opens up trans people to
violence by not recognizing that wow
you're saying that i'm opening up people
to violence by asking whether or not
women are the folks who can have
pregnancies so i'm one i want to note
that one out of five transgender
persons have attempted suicide so i
think it's important because of my line
of questioning because we can't talk
about it because denying that trans
people exist and pretending not to know
that they exist i'm denying that trans
people exist by asking are you if you're
are you about women are you having
pregnancies do you believe that
men can get pregnant
no i don't think so so you're saying
that trans people like this thing and
that leads to violence is this how you
run your classroom are students allowed
to question you or are they also treated
like this or are you interested
opening up people to violence we have a
good time in my class you should join my
best you might learn a lot wow i would
learn a lot i've learned a lot i know
absolutely extraordinary what an
extraordinary magnificent exchange
senator hawley deserves an award for
patience you can tell you look at that
woman's eyes and the crazy is there
because you're you're denying the trans
people exist he goes what what how did i
do that do you think men can get
pregnant uh no well and
you're denying that they exist and she
keeps using this phrase she uses this
phrase people who can get pregnant
people who are capable of pregnancy
all of these euphemisms because she
doesn't want to say the word woman
and she believes the word woman i guess
is transphobic the real irony here is in
the harvard law review this woman kiara
bridges has an article from just just a
couple of years ago this is january 2020
in which she uses the word woman 45
times and the word women 349 times
while talking about abortion she's
speaking she's specifically an expert on
abortion and in just two years
she has completely changed her her mode
of speaking her
mode of thinking about human nature and
now the word woman
with regard to pregnancy and abortion is
considered transphobic so i endorse this
woman for the democrat nominee for
president i think that kiara bridges the
more that we play of kiara bridges on tv
on the internet we put her out on the
campaign trail i think that republicans
are going to win all 57 states if if we
put this woman out there as the face of
the democrat party the democrats seem
fine with this they they call this
berkeley law professor to come testify
they agree with a lot of her premises
and to her credit by the way
i haven't seen a lot of conservatives
defending this point but it we really
should to be fair
when she says that conservatives believe
that trans people don't exist
she's right she's correct conservatives
do not believe that trans people exist
they don't they don't exist that's not
it's
transgender is not a category of being
that is real you can't be that some
people might say well listen i believe
that trans people exist i believe that
people think that they're the opposite
sex they're not really the opposite sex
but i think they think that right so
you're saying people with
gender identity disorder exist you're
saying people with gender dysphoria
exist but transgender people do not
exist they can't exist because to be
transgender is to accept or to even
accept the category of transgenderism is
to accept the premise that a man really
can be a woman
that's why there's a different term for
transgenderism and gender identity
disorder this is why the people who are
men who think that they're women
identify themselves as transgender they
don't identify themselves as people with
gender identity disorder sort of like
saying
uh
you know someone a skinny person who
thinks that he is a fat person is
anorexic
yes he he is
he is anorexic he is not
a
secretly fat person
he is not a
invisibly fat person
in this in this analogy here anorexia
and gender identity disorder and gender
dysphoria those are all medical
conditions that ought to be treated and
corrected transgenderism
male to female or female to male or a
transitioned person would be the the
analogous to a
really skinny very fat person it's just
it's a
it's a logical impossibility it's not a
real category and conservatives don't
want to say this because one will be
de-platformed if you tweet that out if
you say transgender people do not exist
i think that is a direct violation of
twitter's rules and so you could be
taken off the platform for that
so we're not allowed to say that and we
also feel kind of icky we've accepted
the left's premise that it's somehow
bigoted to say that transgender people
do not exist no
people exist confused people exist
sexually
eccentric people exist but transgender
people do not exist they cannot exist
because that is not an actual
ontological category
not to put too fine a point on it i'm so
glad you like that clip i am so close
i'm so close to 1 million subscribers i
need you please i'm asking you've got to
ring that bell like subscribe you've got
to send this channel to your friends say
subscribe right now so that michael can
reach 1 million subscribers and then the
overlords at youtube will completely
nuke his channel and we will accelerate
the liberal
takeover of social media and then we can
finally fight back and get through all
of this madness that's what it's really
that's what it's really all about folks
go subscribe we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]